[Music]
on this Thursday night former U.S
president Trump subpoenaed new damning
evidence from the committee
investigating the U.S Capitol Riot the
central cause of January 6 was one man
and stunning video released from that
day Congressional leaders pleading for
help
ottawa's use of the emergencies act
under scrutiny were those actions
why some provinces say no
cases of covid-19 climb again your best
defense according to doctors
plus a father and son's unbreakable Bond
and love for hockey we
six months the heartwarming story that
could melt the coldest ring
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with big developments in
Washington at the Committee hearing into
the January 6 attempted Insurrection at
the U.S Capitol some stunning previously
unseen video was released it shows
Congressional leaders including house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi being rushed to a
secure room while the building was under
siege as she makes calls and scrambles
to try to end the violence
there has to be some way we can maintain
the sense that people have
that there's some security or some
confidence
that government can function and that we
can elect the president of the United
States
did we go back into session
we did go back into session but now
apparently everybody on the floor is
putting onto your gas masks to prepare
for a bridge if I'm trying to get more
information they're putting on their
tear gas masks
We Believe
I can't we need an area for the housing
members they're all walking over now
through the tunnels
[Music]
Pelosi and others wanted to ensure the
vote to certify that election result it
took place that day and it eventually
did despite the storming of the capital
there was testimony too about how
chillingly close former president Donald
Trump got to Leading the crowd to the
Capitol and that he his inner circle and
the Secret Service knew about the
potential for violence the committee has
built a case that all roads lead to the
former president and today it voted to
subpoena documents and testimony from
Trump Jackson prosco on the dramatic
culmination of a year and a half long
investigation
Cheney I
Miss Lofgren
aye in a unanimous decision the January
6th committee voted to subpoena the man
they blame for the events of that day
former president Donald Trump we must
seek the testimony under oath of January
6th Central player what we are being
told very directly is it's going to take
days for the capital to be okay again
the vote came after the committee
revealed harrowing new footage of
congressional leaders hiding during the
attack pleading for help from government
officials why don't you get the
president to tell them to leave the
capital Mr attorney general and your law
enforcement responsibility a public
statement they should all leave Mr
Schiff
aye there were no new Witnesses but more
new evidence of Trump's plot to ignore
the will of Voters and stay in power
president Trump had a premeditated plan
to declare that the election was
fraudulent and stolen before election
day before he knew the election result
the committee outlined how Trump and his
allies hatched their scheme well in
advance first denial and what Trump's
going to do is just clear Victory right
he's under clear victory but that
doesn't mean he's the winner then the
lies from a man who knew he had lost
there were more votes than there were
voters Donald Trump maliciously repeated
this nonsense to a wide
over and over again his intent was to
deceive
for the first time the committee
revealed some of the one million pieces
of evidence Unearthed from the Secret
Service
agents new days in advance of threats
from armed Trump supporters on January
6th Secret Service agents shared
warnings that the violent mob was acting
at the behest of trump after Trump's
tweet One agent in the secret service's
Intelligence Division immediately warned
POTUS just tweeted about Pence probably
not going to be good for Pence
now regardless of whether or not Trump
ultimately testifies the committee
itself faces some real-time constraints
on its work midterm elections of course
are less than four weeks away the end of
the year and the term of this committee
the committee says they're working on a
final written report we should point out
though Donna that the justice department
is not constrained by any elections and
the committee said today they have
enough evidence for multiple criminal
referrals to the justice department
all right Jackson Prasco in Washington
thank you in Ottawa the use of the
federal emergencies act in February is
under scrutiny that probe was triggered
automatically when prime minister Justin
Trudeau invoked the ACT he says it was
necessary to clear the hundreds of
protesters and vehicles that occupied
streets near Parliament Hill for weeks
and at some border crossings the judge
heading the inquiry says what's at stake
is public confidence in government
the exercise by government of the
exceptional power is given to it by the
emergencies act affects directly or
indirectly all Canadians I'm confident
that the hearings will provide a fair
and thorough process for the
presentation of evidence required
for this Commission
to be able to give the public the
answers to which it is entitled
the inquiry we'll hear from dozens of
witnesses and is operating on a tight
timeline Eric Sorensen looks at what
came from day one of the highly
anticipated inquiry
on the very Street occupied eight months
ago a public inquiry will hear from more
than 60 witnesses as to how it was
brought to an end I'm looking forward to
testifying and I'm happy to be here from
protesters like Tamara Leach all the way
to the prime minister
for more than three weeks last winter
the streets of Ottawa were choked horns
blared and residents were left afraid
and desperate both police planning and
inaction is under scrutiny as is the use
of crowdfunding for protesters there
were blockades near Canada's largest U.S
border crossing in Windsor but the
inquiry commissioner says his primary
focus is squarely on the federal
government's decision itself to invoke
the emergency measures act why did it
declare an emergency
how did it use its powers
and were those actions appropriate in a
rare move the federal government is
releasing some normally privileged
documents to demonstrate its actions
were a last resort is it reasonable and
necessary decision
given the escalating volatile and Urgent
circumstances across the country but was
it urgent across the country in Alberta
roadblock AIDS were cleared before the
emergency Act passed the province told
Ottawa it did not want to see emergency
Powers the existing law enforcement
tools that were already in place were
completely sufficient the Prime Minister
called premiers to consult but
Saskatchewan suggests it wasn't genuine
coming hours before the Act was invoked
the call was not so much about
Consulting as it was about telling the
events of last winter will be presented
through conflicting prisms demonstrators
who say it was a lawful protest the
police who say it was violent the
situation became volatile and it
required an unprecedented response by
mandate the inquiry must conclude by
February just one year after the
protests inquiries such as Air India
spanned up to four years but it's
perhaps the Gomery inquiry that draws
political parallels then Prime Minister
Paul Martin and his predecessor
jean-cretion testified over sponsorships
that severely damaged the liberal
government's popularity one difference
government actions this time played out
largely in public and were defended by
the current prime minister that's why
I'm so happy to be that I offered from
the beginning to be part of a part of
appearing this commission tomorrow the
first witnesses will begin testifying
about what happened in those three
turbulent weeks around Parliament Hill
last winter Eric Sorensen Global News
Ontario's special Investigation Unit
says the two police officers killed on
Tuesday night had not drawn their guns
when they were shot Constable's Devin
Northrup and Morgan Russell were shot at
a home in Innisfil north of Toronto a
third officer did fire on the suspect
who died at the scene police say They
seized an SKS semi-automatic rifle the
Department of Defense has confirmed the
suspect 23-year-old Chris Doncaster was
a private in the armed forces from May
to December of 2020 but left prior to
completing his basic training
in Florida a gunman who killed 17 people
at a high school in Parkland will spend
the rest of his life in jail the jury
spared 24 year old Nicholas Cruz the
death penalty sentencing him to life in
prison without parole Crews stormed
Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School on
Valentine's Day in 2018 opening fire
with a rifle the jury could not
unanimously agree on a death sentence
the victim's families packed the
courtroom today some shaking their heads
others wiping away tears they say
they're angry devastated and that the
jury failed them Crews will be formally
sentenced November 1st
now to the war in Ukraine Russia's
nuclear threat was front and center at a
meeting of NATO defense ministers today
Secretary General Yen stoltenberg warned
of severe consequences if Russia
launches a nuclear strike
we will not go into exactly how we will
respond but of course this will
fundamentally change the nature of the
conflict it will it will
mean that a very important line has been
crossed
the head of the U.N nuclear Watchdog is
back in Ukraine to establish a safety
zone around the nuclear plant in
zaparisia Sirens wailed across the
country after a fourth straight day of
Russian bombardment more than three
dozen people have been killed since
airstrikes have intensified as Crystal
gemancing Reports there is an intense
effort to save people
piles of concrete shards of metal and
heaps of paint those living in mikalaya
are no strangers to the sites of War
surviving each day here is often boiled
down to luck
the wall here is gone four walls are
just gone the governor of mikalayov says
eight cruise missiles slammed into the
Port City this five-story building a
non-military Target blasted open for
more than six hours Crews carefully
sifted through the rubble they could
hear screams for help eventually an 11
year old was taken out alive as he was
being moved to an ambulance he pointed
to the sky and said drone
possibly trying to warn those around him
the child later died in hospital people
fear drones they're loaded with
explosives and used by both sides
Ukrainian officials say an iranian-made
drone often called kamikazes similar to
this one struck an infrastructure site
in the capital region but no details
were shared
for the fourth consecutive day people in
Kiev woke up to air raid sirens and they
continued into the evening it is equally
concerning the head of the international
atomic energy agency talked over one of
those warning sirens acknowledging the
fragile state of Europe's largest
nuclear plant there are days where
things seem to be more calm but then the
next day we are again on a blackout
twice this week the plant was forced to
switch to diesel backup power there are
now four independent observers at the
zaparizia plant as the head of the
agency meets with both sides hoping to
convince them to set up a protection
Zone Russia signaled it is open to the
idea but also claims the facility as its
own after legally annexing the area
while Ukraine urges the world to isolate
Russia Vladimir Putin was in Kazakhstan
pitching his Turkish counterpart on
building an energy Hub Crystal
commencing Global News London
the Biden Administration says there will
be consequences for Saudi Arabia
deciding to cut oil production the U.S
accuses Saudi Arabia of coercing other
OPEC members into making the move today
Saudi Arabia pushed back saying the
Biden administration had asked the oil
cut to be postponed by a month which
could have staved off price Rises at the
pumps until after the midterm elections
a cut to Global oil supply will likely
keep prices high and that could benefit
Russia an OPEC member the International
Energy Association says Opex caught in
production along with inflation and
interest rate hikes could be the Tipping
Point for a worldwide recession
life in one of the world's poorest
countries what Haitians are dealing with
and why they're asking for help that's
coming up
[Music]
there are lots of warnings about food
insecurity in the poorest parts of the
world well one of those is Haiti nearly
half that country's population doesn't
have enough to eat and as Mike Armstrong
explains there are pleas for the world
to help
it is a country in chaos Haiti has known
trouble before both natural and man-made
but many say this is worse than it's
been in decades
H this man took to the streets he says
over unemployment inflation and
insecurity
the situation has gotten worse week by
week public transportation is paralyzed
schools are closed businesses are
shutting down fuel food and even clean
water are harder and harder to find
world food program is struggling to help
it recently lost more than eight million
dollars worth of aid
enough food to feed more than 200 000
people was stolen two of our four
warehouses were deliberately targeted
looted and pillaged
another growing problem is cholera there
have only been 18 confirmed deaths but
more than 250 suspected cases that as
hospitals can barely stay open some have
gone public saying if a patient needs
surgery they should bring fuel to run
the generator
now it was under those conditions the
acting prime minister made this appeal
to the International Community Ariel Ari
is asking for military intervention by
countries like the U.S and Canada to
fight the gang problem paralyzing the
country well that request pushed more
people into the streets to protest
foreign intervention critics say has
been tried and failed we keep doing the
same thing but yes Pierre is the
director of Elections and part of a
group calling for a new interim
government and dialogue if the
International Community wants to help he
says it can support Haiti's struggling
police force with weapons and pay we
have 13 000 in police officers they need
to be equipped while Haitian police are
still waiting for new armored vehicles
from Canada delivery has been delayed
spokesperson for Global Affairs Canada
meanwhile tells Global News Ottawa is
still considering the Haitian prime
minister's appeal for help Mike
Armstrong Global News
a Resurgence in covid-19 ahead the
latest variants to start spreading
[Music]
winter is approaching and that means
what was feared is in fact happening the
number of cases of covid-19 are on the
rise hospitalizations across the country
are rising to reaching levels not
recorded since May in some places the
bulk of those patients are in Quebec
Ontario and Alberta the cases are
largely being driven by a sub-variant of
Omicron and as Jamie Maraca explains a
lack of restrictions waning immunity and
the threat of new mutations could fuel a
prolonged surge this fall and winter
updated covid-19 vaccines now available
to most Canadians Target the covid
sub-variants still dominant here but
Health experts are now warning the virus
is changing mutations are happening at
any time in you know randomly and any
part of the world we see now that the
new variants or subarian that they are
popping now they are basically escaping
the immune system in Europe the return
to normal life has sparked the start of
another wave seen as a marker for what
North America can expect next this U.S
expert is watching the climbing cases
closely this time the picture is a bit
muddled because the rise of cases
doesn't seem to be associated with any
one particular variant you are seeing a
rise in ba5 but you're seeing some of
these new I like to call them Scrabble
variants those variants have reached
mutations in the hundreds and while some
die off without much concern others have
recently been added to a new watch list
by the World Health Organization in
Canada omicron's ba5 makes up the
majority the ba5 more closely resembles
the new
Scrabble variants than the original
lineage so you're more likely to get
protected if you've getting that new
bivalent booster Health Canada approved
Pfizer strain specific shot Friday this
week the company confirmed the vaccine
generated a strong immune response but
it did not disclose the levels of
antibodies moderna's bivalent booster
has been approved since early September
still in the last six months just 16
percent of Canadians have been boosted
leaving many prime doctors say to catch
covet again the best policy is to get
vaccinated even if you had infection
advice that's only helpful if vaccines
keep up with covid year after year Jamie
moroccer Global News
a hockey heart warmer next the Habs fan
finding some comfort in the face of a
serious illness
[Music]
if you're a hockey Super Fan you know
the drill you buy all the gear and most
importantly you watch every game well
lifelong Montreal Canadiens fan Kevin
Murphy is all over that stuff but he
couldn't make this season's home opener
he's been diagnosed with cancer and he
couldn't leave his Toronto hospital so
instead as Mike drulay reports his son
brought the Habs experience to him
yes these were the best of times for
Kevin and cavi Murphy it didn't matter
where they were when the Montreal
Canadiens were playing
[Applause]
so long as they were together life was
good me and my dad have always just been
so tight and we've always just bonded
over everything but Taki and the Habs
have been one of the strongest ones for
Sharon it was like that from the day
cavi was adopted in India you can see it
in their pictures the easy smiles
between loving sun and proud dad but
then and there's always one of those
Kevin was diagnosed with kidney cancer
in 2019. they thought they had it beat
but then it didn't really hit too hard
until this summer
um it was this summer when we were given
the the six months and um
yeah it's been it's been really tough
with Kevin in palliative care cavi went
to the Hockey Hall of Fame to collect
his thoughts it's where his dad used to
go all the time to see the statue of his
favorite player Ken Dryden and there
under the statue he knew what he had to
do so I went home immediately grabbed
all our stuff all our jerseys all our
figures cards and that night while he
was asleep I put them all up in his room
Kevin woke up to this he couldn't go to
the Hall of Fame so cavi brought it to
him he was kind of speechless kevi
sleeps at the hospital now all the
nurses know him and if there's a Game
Father and Son are watching it I want to
be there with him and learn from him as
much as I can before
he's gone where most would be
inconsolable cavi shows a maturity
Beyond his years I mean how old are you
I'm 17. you don't seem 17. yeah
unfortunately I've had to grow up pretty
fast and no doubt his dad is proud of
the man he's become Mike drolet Global
News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is crossgale Lake near
Bridgetown Nova Scotia we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to us and
thanks for watching Farah Nasser will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow and I'll see
you Saturday at 7 for the new reality
bye-bye
[Music]